you know i always love coming down to
subaru of las vegas and telling you guys
what's going on in the community and
what they're doing with their amazing
cars but
i never get to introduce you to burton
hughes himself so i want to get to know
you i want to educate everybody about
the guy behind the love here at subaru
of las vegas so
what inspired you to get into the
automotive industry and just kind of
tell us your journey before you got here
well rocky when i was 10 years old i had
an argument with god
i loved cars from a little kid i loved
cars and but my dad was a pastor and i
knew i had
um a calling to ministry as well
and and so uh i i thought i had won the
argument and i went into the car
business at 19 years old but then i
ended up
studying for pastoral ministry and and i
have actually been doing both for over
30 years
and i think you know what is a minister
it's someone who serves
and so
that is the core value that i that i
lead with here and and it's really what
drives the love promise as we live it
out on a daily basis at subaru of las
vegas incredible and and for those who
don't know how do you guys incorporate
that here at subaru las vegas you know
we get involved in so many great great
initiatives and you know we're right at
the back to school
time of year and so we've got several
things happening uh for for our students
for our educators but you know what one
of the things that really um stirs my
heart is you know the nevad nevada
childhood cancer foundation does a camp
every year for critically ill children
and uh and they do it at torino ranch on
the backside of mount charleston for two
weeks 200 kids that are pretty much
locked up in a hospital get to come out
and they get to just enjoy life
and to do that every year is just an
amazing thing now how does that attitude
trickle down to your team and your
employees here at subaru las vegas you
know there were so many that signed up
for camp cartwheel it's called there are
so many i thought are we going to have
anybody left at the dealership you know
it's it's just
doing the things that we do in the
community it just spreads and we realize
giving is so much better than just
receiving we have a subaru of las vegas
read to me book drive we're collecting
new and gently used books here all
through the month of august it's it's
gonna go to spread the word nevada great
organization uh that we've partnered
with for for years uh and maybe just to
mention that we have partnered uh with
the marion b earl elementary school for
the month and we're going to be
we've committed to giving them twelve
thousand five hundred dollars for the
educators to spend on their students you
give so much love to the community but
also you give so much love to your
customers i think that maybe you know
the fact that the inventories are
extremely low but you know what we're
still uh we are ordering cars people can
special order cars
super modus finance is actually locking
in rates if you order a car and it takes
a little longer to get and now you know
where that subaru love promise comes
from right from burton hughes thank you
for for helping our community and having
your customers leave here with safe
vehicles
and so much love thank you rocky